dans un instant sur France 2 c'est la
rentrée Télématin avec vous Thomas Soto
je crois que vous avez une nouvelle
camarade de classe qui nous rejoint à
partir d'aujourd'hui et c'est le premier
scoop de Télé Matin regardez première
exclusive de Marie Porto bonjour Marie
bonjour bienvenue Bienvenue chez toi tu
as les clés de la maison maintenant donc
tranquille je vais quand même te poser
quelques est-ce que tu as bien dormi
c'est pas très bien dormi maintenant
ça part d'une volonté du président
Emmanuel Macron de recevoir tous les
partis représentés au Parlement pour un
colloque qui a donc été nommé les
rencontres de Saint-Denis et l'objectif
c'est bâtir des textes législatifs pour
ouvrir potentiellement la voie à des
référendum mais tous ensemble
exactement les thèmes des discussions
pour cette première à la situation
internationale et ses conséquences pour
la France l'efficacité de l'action
publique les nuits d'émeutes que nous
avons vécu une jeune automobiliste a été
interpellé en état débriété sur le
parking d'un fast-food dans le Loiret et
en fait il se trouve qu'elle avait un
petit peu trop bu parce qu'elle fêtait
son permis de conduire donc au final
elle a embouti une voiture et elle était
complètement énervée de cette situation
la police est arrivée et elle n'a rien
trouvé de mieux que de cracher sur les
poulies finalement elle a fini au poste
et au poste s'est taper la tête contre
la table et donc et ensuite aller aux
urgences alors le président veut
convaincre les oppositions de saisir
cette main tendue loyalement
Barbara
ça veut dire que pendant le grand débat
par exemple il tendait des mains mais
c'était pas le voyage
j'ai cru comprendre
10 ans
au pouvoir
avec la médiatisation d'aujourd'hui
c'est immense
mais c'est la deuxième qui c'est le
peuple qui décide non non
on s'y habitue c'est une drogue dure
10 ans c'est largement suffisant malgré
leur caractère sociable les singes de la
troupe ne sont pas à l'abri de quelques
querelles
le rôle du chef est de protéger les
petits et leur mère et surtout de
satisfaire les moindres désirs des
femelles
[Musique]
mais ce n'est pas aussi facile qu'il y
paraît
[Musique]
vous vous êtes séparés pour quelle
raison
et pourquoi parce qu'il comprenait pas
que j'en avais besoin et du coup le
temps est monté c'est quitté on est
resté fâché jusqu'au jour aujourd'hui
plus rien attendez l'exceptionnel cette
histoire Liliana donc avec ton ex Yanis
vous aviez une relation explosive et
vous vous êtes quitté lors d'une énième
dispute à cause d'un rouleau de papier
toilette qu'il n'a pas voulu te donner
[Musique]
les femelles sont exigeantes
et elle demande une attention constante
dans cette région montagneuse leur
épaisse fourrure les protège du froid
mais il faut les pousser tous les jours
[Musique]
si le jeune chef ne comble pas les
femelles elle le remplaceront par un
autre mâle plus attentionné
la dernière dispute c'était à cause de
papier cul voilà Yanis tu me confirme
que votre dernière dispute c'était pour
une histoire de papier toilette
exactement on avait plus de papier
toilette et du coup j'ai dit j'ai besoin
de papier toilette je le demande
d'acheter du papier toilette je vais
ramener du papier toilette j'ai ramené
des mouchoirs
[Musique]
qui est la nouvelle présentatrice Marie
porte tolano et bien pour répondre au
point je crois qu'il s'agit de Marie
portelano elle-même et vous avez fait
toute la presse vous avez fait toute la
presse c'est le gros transfert le
Parisien qui vous avez déclaré Télématin
ça ne se refuse pas évidemment qu'on dit
ça avant d'arriver mais quand le 15
février faudra se réveiller à 2h30 par
-2 °c on en reparlera du sensorfus pas
alors est-ce qu'on va décaler la rentrée
scolaire au 18 septembre et ben non
évidemment que non c'est évident mais
Olivier vérante parole du gouvernement
coupe courra la rumeur selon laquelle la
rentrée scolaire serait décalée tout est
parti d'une vidéo un canular publié sur
Tik Tok vu de millions de fois la
rentrée est-elle vraiment décalée la
réponse oui en effet au vu du conseiller
aux politiques actuel entre la Chine et
la Russie et des fortes tensions
Emmanuel Macron s'est vu dans
l'obligation de réintégrer le service
militaire via le cursus scolaire dans
cette même interview vous avez dit ceci
vous avez dit ceci j'aime cette
atmosphère de travail quand il fait nuit
et qu'il n'y a personne c'est exactement
la phrase qui avait dit de Patrick
Poivre d'Arvor à l'époque donc deux
semaines de vacances supplémentaires
seraient ainsi nécessaire pour
s'organiser c'est incroyable et pourtant
le doute est semé j'arrive même pas à
savoir si c'est vrai ou si c'est faux
c'est archi faux donc les élèves sont
attendus lundi en classe admis
bravo Thomas bon égalité avec ton frère
tu es content
non pourquoi tu es pas content
[Musique]
à me dire je suis meilleur que toi je
suis meilleur que toi et le seul jour il
y a un examen il a la même mention que
moi donc force poser des questions
sauf que moi je veux devenir un très
grand avocat
1990 enfants à la rue dont 480 de moins
de 3 ans c'est le constat terrible du
dernier rapport de l'Unicef les chiffres
n'ont jamais été aussi alarmants depuis
la mise en place de ce baromètre il y a
5 ans d'autant plus qu'ils sont
sous-évalués puisqu'ils ne prennent en
compte que les familles qui appellent le
115 la France manque de place
d'hébergement d'urgence merci beaucoup
c'était la première fois que j'ai
assisté et ben c'était pas mal
merci
à la semaine prochaine ou pas